mirror mirror on the wall who's the real
villain of them all it's possible that
the heroes in Disney's descendants are
actually the villains it all depends on
how you look at it mal promised us
freedom delivering only lies ever since
the very first Disney fairy tale we were
certain that we knew who the heroes were
and we thought we knew who the real
villains were as well but what if we
were wrong about all of it it all
depends on the way you look at it from a
different perspective the so-called
heroes in Disney's descendants look a
lot like villains in fact the heroes of
auradon are capable of some pretty
wicked deeds what do you call it when
people are locked up and separated from
society prison right but in descendants
Balon beasts rounded up all the evil
villains and trapped them on a small
island we're pretty sure they weren't
given a fair trial either so when it
lands were only one or two people decide
who is guilty and who deserves freedom
that's usually the result of
power-hungry tyrants ruling the kingdom
that's not exactly what you pictured
when you saw Beauty and the Beast
ice-skating together while birds landed
on them right well as it turns out they
might not be as pure hearted as they
pretend to be even if the crimes of
Maleficent Ursula the Evil Queen Cruella
Jafar and Hades are undeniable what
about all the villain kids they are
innocent victims in this whole thing
their only crime was being born on the
wrong side of the barrier sure this is
the reason that Ben wanted to bring a
select few of vks over to our dine from
the Isle but why only a few will get to
that more a little later in this video
for now let's focus on the grievances of
one particularly bitter villain who is
stuck on the Isle the descendents three
trailer titled meet Hades was very
telling it shows a side of life on the
Isle that we hadn't seen before in the
trailer Hades laments at the fact that
Belle and beast decide long ago to cast
out those who didn't fit the art on mold
they saw themselves fit to decide who
was good or bad
Hades claims that Bell and beast
banished everyone who disagreed with
them off to a crowded little island with
no magic no freedom and no hope Hades
believes it has driven him to madness
the Lord of the underworld possesses a
very thought-provoking question is every
person on the Isle really evil do they
actually deserve to be stuck there
that's a valid question why do you bail
and beasts have the final say and who
stays in auradon and who is cast out to
the isle they created a lot of disdain
and bad feelings in the hearts of the
villains and it's only natural that they
would harbor grudges against the people
who force them to be prisoners in this
dark miserable place if the villains had
access to a fair due process they
wouldn't have had to resort to other
means to find justice when you think of
it from Hades his point of view it
doesn't seem right the villain kids
shouldn't have to pay for the crimes of
their parents and even with Ben's
gesture to move some villain kids off
the aisle and into auradon so many kids
who were left behind
additionally the villains on the Isle
were stripped of everything that once
made them powerful not only were they
imprisoned on the Isle but they also had
their titles removed and they were
unable to access any magic imagine how
difficult that must have been for
Sorceress's these villains lost
everything and they had little hope of
ever getting it back it only makes sense
that they would plot and scheme to be
reunited with their magical powers of
course they would do whatever it took to
get their hands on fairy godmothers wand
so they could free themselves the only
alternative is to live out their days in
a tiny hopeless island with no shot at
redemption that would drive just about
anybody to madness if you think about it
it probably wasn't very smart of Beast
and Belle to pull all of their enemies
together on one tiny little island they
literally have nothing else to do but
plot their revenge together the villains
all have one common enemy the people who
imprison them on the Isle so it only
makes sense that they would get together
to plan an uprising but most shocking of
all is at beeston bail broadcast odd on
TV on the Isle that seems like a mean
thing to do they are rubbing their
freedom in the villains faces they are
enjoying all these fancy parties nice
schools and new friends while all the
villains are forced to watch now that's
pure evil and let's talk about the
villain kids mal Evie Carlos and Jay
we're the only kids selected to move to
our Don from the Isle why just these
four kids aren't all of the kid
on the aisle innocent even if they are a
little bit misguided so it makes sense
that the other villains and DK's would
presume that mal and her crew thought
that they were better than everybody
else
Hades even says it seems like they
turned their backs on everyone on the
Isle who gave Ben the authority to only
pick these four kids that seems like a
pretty harsh process for dizzy and the
other potentially sweet villain kids who
were left to rot on the Isle not being
chosen obviously made them angry all of
those bad feelings are causing a perfect
storm of hatred and revenge and the Isle
is facing auradon making the Royal
Kingdom an easy target although then
might have meant well his plan was far
from brilliant and the cherry on top is
AG mal is dating Ben whose parents are
responsible for locking the villains up
it's no wonder some of them feel that
mal has turned her back on her villain
friends and family now said she wanted
to be good in the first descendants
movie but how good is she really looking
at her shady past is an instant reminder
of how cruel she once was take her
history with the supposed scallywag
villain of the sea uma if you read about
mal and uma in the books
it looks like uma is actually a victim
of Mao's mean stunts a perfect example
of mouth' bullying behavior happened two
years ago on the Isle of the Lost
Malin uma once teamed up to prank her
Ella De Vil mal seemingly fell off the
docks into the water and uma jumped in
to save her when she appeared to be
drowning so how does now return the
favor by dumping a bucket of shrimp on
whom his head that is some Mean Girls
stuff right there apparently after that
incidents no matter how many times you
mat ride to wash the shrimp smell out of
her hair it never fully came out she was
disgusted by the fishy smell and to make
matters worse now I got everyone to call
her shrimpy and mouth still calls her
shrimpy to this day during her arm
wrestling match with uma in descendants
two they exchanged some wicked banter
uma tells now that she didn't buy her
whole Prince's act for a minute you
could stick at er all the villains
there's still ability mouse taps back
saying that uma can slap a pirate hat on
but she's still just a shrimpy that's
cold mal we thought you said you chose
to be good for years
uma has been out for revenge against the
girl who made her hair smell like shrimp
and gave her that horrible nickname
so basically Huma spends most of her
life being bossed around by her mom and
backstabbed by her friends and to top it
all off she's stuck on the aisle for
crimes she didn't commit the crimes that
her mother have forced her into this
unbearable existence and we know we're
not supposed to root for uma but we
really hope she was finally able to get
the fish smell out of her hair it only
makes sense that she would do whatever
it takes to get off the aisle and so she
kidnapped mouths boyfriend attempted to
trade him in for fairy godmothers blonde
and placed a love spell and then to get
back at now sure this has villain
written all over it but the word
desperate also comes to mind so why can
we really blame Emma for her actions not
really because in the end she really had
no other choice
Mao was supposed to liberate the villain
kids from the Isle but she never even
mentioned it to Ben at all Evie was the
only one who proposed the idea of
getting some of the villain kids off the
aisle and into auradon prep the fact
that mal didn't think of asking her
boyfriend the king to free the BK's is
questionable at best in fact it makes
her look selfish and cruel so is now the
evil one or are Ben and his parents the
evil villains of the story we love you
to join us to auradon prep will you come
sign king bed we know that dizzy is
going to be a part of the argon prep
crew moving forward but what about the
rest of the kids it doesn't really seem
fair when you think about it now hasn't
exactly used her magic for virtuous and
noble causes since you left the aisle in
the first Descendants movie she casts a
love spell on Ben so she can trick him
and still fairy godmothers one she gets
angry with Jane and uses her spell book
to restore Jane's hair to its original
look now has proven that she is just as
capable of manipulating magic to get
revenge
that makes her no difference than Emma
right so what sets these two apart is it
only the fact that then shows mal evey
Carlos and Jay instead of
Uma Harry and Gil mal once said that she
felt she didn't belong in auradon which
proved that she sees herself as a
villain and not a hero in descendants -
she runs back to the Isle deep down mal
is afraid that she is really the bad guy
that must be very confusing for a girl
who is trying to be good from what we've
seen in the recent descendants three
trailers mal could be embracing her dark
past and evil roots the trailers show
mal and uma fighting on the same side so
is it possible that now decides to go
back to her wicked ways and team up with
uma to overthrow ara dime
that would require uma to set aside her
quest for revenge against smell food uma
is pretty tough and strategic she could
use mal to get what she wants and if
Hades his mouths dad there will still be
a strong pool for her to reconnect with
her family her only other parent is a
wizard so she is probably feeling the
absence of parental figures right about
now so what if now realizes that it has
been Ben and his parents who are the
real villains all along will she side
with her dad and uma to tear down the
barrier around the isle and liberate the
innocence villain kids who have been
wrongfully exiled or will she side with
Ben and all her new fancy friends and we
still can't decide whose side Hades is
on right now appears that he is only
looking out for himself but who knows
how long it's been since he's seen his
daughter he may have a change of heart
when he reconnects with mal and with Ben
becoming a beast like his father he
could go through a pretty dark period
when he becomes the very evil his
parents have been trying to fight with
this new perspective of villain life on
the Isle you have to wonder who are the
real villains of the story do you think
that now then and the people of Aragon
are the real villains and Disney's
descendants could Yuma and the rest of
the villains on the Isle actually be the
heroes of their story let us know what
your verdict is in the comment section
below
thanks for watching the things be sure
to subscribe to our channel to be the
first to see our latest videos don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up see you later
[Music]